[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que para mí es un ser humano desde la
perspectiva de tres letras que van a
significar tres palabras y empezamos
ser ecuatorianos e h
el conocimiento es todo lo que un ser
humano desde mi perspectiva pone en su
mente como un disco duro de una de un
computador
las habilidades son las que nacemos y
las características que tenemos
como personas como seres humanos pero
hay algo que une a los dos desde mi
perspectiva de ser humano y es la
actitud
cuándo
tuve un cáncer que sacaron el 40 por
ciento de mi hígado y un tumor de 40
centímetros
me dieron 15 días de vida
y fui al médico con la quimioterapia y
me dice
notará matices porque no me das pena y
si vienes a morirte no soy yo tu médico
y al otro día regrese
diez días más tarde a la quimioterapia
nunca más me quejé y mi actitud de vida
fue que quería demostrarle al médico y a
mí que era posible que iba a morir si es
que era necesario a los 15 días que dijo
el presbítero en hospitality pero que
jamás me quejaría ante nadie peor ante
mí mismo
entonces quería empezar con esto porque
el conocimiento medio porque antes de
ser cocinero
quería ser sacerdote y estudié cuatro
años de teología y seis años de
filosofía
el chile
pero quería ser sacerdote de claustro
entonces cuando me mandaron los la
universidad católica pontificia de
concepción en chile
a que venga a revalidar mi título y al
año sabático para ver si era verdad lo
que yo quería
una mujer que en cana me hizo conocer
que el mundo ha sido de colores entonces
hasta era blanco y negro no más para mí
y dije hasta aquí quedó así es que ha
sido más divertida esta parte de la vida
y decidí cambiar así es que vino
rogelio liza el rector el canciller y me
dijeron pero leoncito sigue todos los
sacerdotes viven ese proceso para saber
pero yo no no es honesto
y parte de mi criterio como ser humano
es que él es elevado era parte de un
ejercicio al cual yo me había formado y
el día que lo perdí
puedo mentirle al mundo menos a mí
aparte de eso ha sido super divertido
entonces
ahí entendí que la actitud iba a cambiar
todo lo que marcaría mi vida como un
doctorado de filosofía a los 22 años con
una licenciatura en hotelería
y como una responsabilidad de una esposa
nadie me quería dar trabajo
y empecé a trabajar en la hotelería
ese viento
que la actitud de ser sacerdote o la
actitud clerical de servicio también se
puede hacer desde otra perspectiva
servir en cualesquiera ámbito a mí me
tocó servir en la hotelería fui gerente
general de un hotel
y entendí que la experiencia de un hotel
no se vive en la habitación solamente
sino en mínimo tres veces por día la
oportunidad de hacer feliz a la gente a
través de la cocina y la actitud de
servicio que falle la técnica jamás la
actitud
y vino un hombre que cuando yo regrese
de parís todos saben quién es jorge
enrique don
y yo traigo de parís con mi maestría de
estudiar alta gastronomía después de
haber estado en la san francisco me dice
leoncito
he comido
y me llevaste a la nostalgia de los 22
años que viví en parís como secretario
de pablo neruda
pero lo que has traído es una copia
intenté ser buena cocina ecuatoriana con
tu nombre y apellido y que tenga una
identidad
porque por más bueno que sea lo que
traigas será una copia y una copia jamás
tendrá personalidad ni identidad
catorce años más tarde este libro gana
el segundo mejor libro de gastronomía
del mundo entre diez y seis mil 800
libros de cocina en beijing
tres meses antes de morir él era testigo
de eso y su hija que evitó el texto
alejandra dun
y los angela escriben parte del prólogo
jorge enrique era el turquito como lo
decíamos todos apeó y dice dios debe
comer así los bienes de fines de semana
cuando se ha portado bien toda la semana
pero no era mi comida era su comida que
le llevaba a la nostalgia de esos
sabores
que habían llevado y esos 15 años que
recorría el país en cocinas de vi
bandera de mercado de carretera y de un
hombre que me motivó a que averigüe la
cocina no me la inventé porque los
famosos cocineros de moda dicen cocina
de fusión que a veces caemos en la
provocación de ser cocina de confusión
fui las carreteras las matronas las
mamás y las abuelas generosamente
abrieron sus puertas compartieron sus
recetas y para vio hacer una receta le
decía usted me enseñó a hacer esta
receta permítame prepararla porque la
única o el único juez que me debe probar
y aprobar es usted no yo
así es que cada receta cuando me llaman
y me dicen señor león su libro ganó el
segundo mejor el libro de cocina entre
16.000 y 1800 libros de cocina del mundo
yo poco inteligente y muy torpe le digo
y cómo así
el interlocutor me dice es el único
libro que tiene alma detrás de un
recetario y los 16.000 otros libros sólo
son recetarios de cocina porque conté la
antropología y sociología de donde venía
cada plato y eso fue lo que me hizo
distinto y decía de que un grande
un deportista cuando con mí el plato de
su abuela y le dije me permite probar
que le salga su abuela ya no podía
aprobar me lo aprobó el su mamá y sus
hermanos hasta ahora dice que lo único
que se respeta en la nostalgia de los
afectos es la cocina
pero una mujer que también me enseñó y
qué es
la que todos conocemos rosalía arteaga
ella es la directora mundial de los
países amazónicos que se llama la
presidenta panas panamá zonas me llevo a
cocinar en todo brasil
con productos amazónicos yo católico
apostólico y loja no llevará a ser
cocina amazónica no entendía mucho pero
entendí que ellos podían aportar con
productos y venía la creatividad y
creamos un texto y un libro que hoy es
uno de los mejores libros que reposa
entre los textos más conservados con el
nombre el otro sabor del mundo los
platos amazónicos
y vuelvo el conocimiento las actitudes
conocí a una mujer cuando era muy niño
no tuvo acceso a la información pero
tuvo acceso al poder de la convicción y
una mujer como tránsito amaguaña
demostró al mundo
que a través de sus cocinas y sus
productos
combinaba y compartía un ejercicio de
vivir en comunidad
e
cuando no sé para ustedes que son muy
jovencitos todos se acuerdan cuando
había todas las voces todas en quito
yo todavía era estudiante de gastronomía
en la san francisco
osvaldo me decía leoncito ven a hacer
tus prácticas de cocina en mi casa y hoy
vi cocinaba para todos ahí pude conocer
a los intelectuales de la música a
través de compartir platos de comida
mercedes sosa silvio rodríguez pablo
milanés todos serios pude conocer allí
y yo con vergüenza de salir de la cocina
primero por saber si los platos serán
aceptados
y uno de los recuerdos que marcó mi vida
fue el de mercedes sosa
se levanta de la mesa y dice quiero
conocer a la gente a la persona que
preparo esta comida es la más parecida a
la cocina de tucumán que cocinaba a mi
abuela y era asesina de loja con yuca
papa con mapa huirá y mote pillo inmotec
asado así es que las cocinas nos unen a
una región de latinoamérica lo que
separan son los límites que crearon los
seres humanos
cuando conocí a esta mujer que todo el
mundo sabe 1960 fue miss ecuador llegó a
parís y conquistó siendo una de las
actrices más cotizadas con películas
como el hall de restaurant de hoy y
shawn look
conquistó el mundo quiero decir las
habilidades no todos no hacemos con las
mismas pero hay que saber
identificarnos en que estamos nosotros
convencidos de lo que sea un filósofo y
casi cura que se haga cocinero raro no
es cierto
pero dicen que queda bien algo por lo
menos la sopa y decirles que echar
carpas tenía una habilidad
y cuando pude cocinar en italia
coincidencialmente
decía que el tiempo que está ya lo único
que le volvió al ecuador fue cuando
comió un plato de comida porque cuando a
mí me invitan a cocinar en un país
no va solo el cocinero en mi maleta
llevo
ingredientes porque yo no sé cocinar
cocina ecuatoriana sin ingredientes
ecuatorianos
y aquí viene un ejercicio aquí me ven un
poco agotado después del sial de parís
con uno de los mejores chocolateros del
planeta
atribuye esa pan
él es el chocolatero número 7 y me dice
que es esto le digo es una mousse de
chocolate con sabor a maracuyá sin crema
sin nata y sin mantequilla no puede ser
me decía en francés no nace para pepsi
le digo es posible estamos cree para
michelle obama porque ya no come lácteos
y me dice enseña a ser para mis
chocolaterías y serías el primer
cocinero que viene a mi planta y
crearemos una barra de chocolate el león
ahí estoy en su planta de chocolate
creando una barra de chocolate era la
actitud que hacía que yo entienda y
conozca esta gente y aquí estoy
recibiendo uno de los premios más
importantes de cocinas con una
condecoración de en canadá y bueno estas
son cositas que fueron pasando seguimos
creo aquí soy el primer foro mundial de
gastronomía no me llevo por lo
inteligente o simpático que sea sino
fueron las cocinas que podía hermanar y
todos los países de latinoamérica en el
primer foro mundial en méxico y en
argentina a contar que somos que comemos
porque antes de aprender a bailar cantar
y pintar aprendemos a comer
seguimos luego pasa
gloria lópez es la directora de la
unesco por 22 años en parís que
consiguió el primer patrimonio cultural
intangible sea la cocina de uno de los
pueblos de méxico y ella me enseñó que
nunca tenga vergüenza de mi raíz y
dignifique porque un día todos los
países deberían tener el nombramiento de
patrimonio cultural intangible
mi nombre en embajador de wheat y una de
las mejores aguas si empiezo a mostrar
el agua de wheat y como un catador de
aguas y mostrando la uitice por todo el
mundo con públicos de mil dos mil
personas en londres en parís en nueva
york en quito en guayaquil y a capacitar
a los topos restaurantes como catar agua
y la experiencia de como comer con agua
y mar y dar perfectamente una comida que
corresponde a llevar la mejor agua de
deshielo del planeta a las mesas del
mundo
y siempre combinaba seguimos porque no
algo pasa que no lo continua
esta es la casa de oswaldo guayasamín
volvemos por el comedor en donde se
abrió 19 años más tarde su comedor su
cocina y utilizamos el mismo mantel para
cuando vino hábitat y el directorio de
hábitat se sirvió la cocina con los
mismos platos que fuimos sirviendo la
cocina del ecuador ante el mundo
seguimos
utilizar 14 servicios y 7 copas es un
ejercicio que deberíamos saber todos por
cultura general
decir porque cuando uno se gradúa y le
dicen o se va a algún lugar del planeta
y le ponen un servicio completo o aquí y
te dicen en dónde estudiaste cómo se
llama tu papá cómo se llama tu mamá
digno hijo de tu madre por lo que haces
y representas en un comportamiento del
más básico que es el comportamiento
social en una mesa y la menú de
despedida de michelle obama ella tiene
un proyecto mundial que se llama cómo
mejorar
la nutrición de los eeuu como ejemplo
para el mundo decide combinar a los
cinco autores de los mejores libros de
cocina y por coincidencia estaba yo
y voy y me dice todas las cocinas del
mundo ya he comido pero jamás he comido
chochos pepas de sambo chocolate y flor
de la canela'
quisiera que vengas a cocinar y allí
dice el menú de despedida para 1.100
invitados
horchata
comparecían de frutas con champagne que
fue el brindis que se hizo
a una entrada de 1 mil hoja de harina de
papa con harina de quinua rellena de pan
gora y cangrejo en una salsa de albahaca
con un aceite de aguacate
una langosta rellena con un puré de
hongo de maíz y un caramelo de chicha
con aceite de aguacate seguimos
y aquí tenemos uno de los platos que
para mí significó mucho la nutrición de
ecuador- quinua con los 14 mariscos que
exporta el ecuador en una salsa de
picante de ají sin picante y pimientos
asados
una carne una un puré de papas con
cúrcuma y ají sin picante con una carne
en salsa de mortiño seguimos y este
plato que ganó el choco face en londres
compactar y chocolate una carne con
chocolate 100% packard y en almíbar de
pétalos de rosas y perfume de flor de la
canela'
una que emule rellena de baba cost
hecho con caramelo y unas frutillas que
fueron llevadas incluso de cuenca bueno
es hora de tener hambre no
seguimos y como se acabe el tiempo la un
fondant de chocolate la mousse de
chocolate que está sin crema sin
mantequillas y nata y un cacao blanco
con guanábana y chirimoya fue el postre
y seguimos con el café de loja ganador
de la taza dorada mundial los macarrones
de más chica de mortiño de capuchino y
de chocolate y de petición o después del
café bocadillos de loja con blanqueados
de loja así es que cuando el
conocimiento crece la oportunidad
aparece y yo quiero pedir disculpas por
venir a contar una historia que
probablemente no les interese pero por
venir y no dormiré si se durmieron no
roncar o no me permitieron hacer mi
trabajo
[Música]
[Aplausos]